[Música]
tengo dos fechas importantes en mi vida
el 28 de febrero de 1960 fecha en la que
nací y el 31 de mayo de 1970 fecha en la
que volví a nacer
sobrevivir al terremoto y a la luz
que sepultó la hermosa ciudad de yungay
de mi infancia
en medio de ese desastre la papa estaba
ahí
para salvarme del hambre a mí ya muchos
que sobrevivieron a esa tremenda
tragedia tranquils
muchos años después
de haberme formado como ingeniera
agrónoma en la universidad nacional
agraria la molina
en los años 90
decidí regresar al campo
a reencontrarme con aquel tubérculo
que me salvó
el logro de mí que esté acá con ustedes
en esa época
el sector papelero del país atravesaba
por una crisis
tremenda diría yo porque había pérdida
de biodiversidad
baja productividad
pérdida de conocimientos ancestrales
falta de organización para acceder a
estos mercados modernos que exigen
volumen calidad y formalidad y lo más
grave que pasaba en ese tiempo es que el
consumo de la papa en el país se había
venido abajo había caído tremendamente
la papa es el cultivo
más importante del país es el cultivo
que más se consume en el perú
somos el país originario de la papa está
científicamente demostrado
que la primera papa que el hombre comió
fue aquí en este territorio hace ocho
mil años
a orillas del lago titicaca
el nombre de la especie
la primera especie cultivada es solando
un este no tom no los quiere complicar
solanum este no ton
es la primera especie cultivada
son la nube este no tomo se obtuvo en el
clip de dos variedades silvestres las
especies silvestres son aquellas que
crecen espontáneamente
esas no se come
las especies cultivadas son las que
intervienen la mano del hombre mientras
en el mundo comen dos a cuatro papas
aquí en nuestro territorio tenemos miles
de papas
en los años 60
de acuerdo a
datos del ministerio de agricultura
consumíamos 120 kilos por persona al año
en los 70
dejamos de consumir papas
comenzamos a consumir
arroz y fideos en cantidades
industriales
nuestro consumo de papas cayó
tremendamente
en los años 90 a 35 kilos personas año
y eso que trajo
baja de precio y caos en el campo
por eso en el 2001
junto a mis colegas paperos por ahí
donde está
fundé a there's perú la asociación para
el desarrollo sostenible del perú
somos una organización no gubernamental
de desarrollo
trabajamos proyectos centrados en la
familia para desarrollar el campo
una de las primeras iniciativas
que impulsamos
fue la creación del 30 de mayo como día
nacional de la papa
investigando me di cuenta de que había
países
que celebraban un día nacional de la
papa
eeuu inglaterra alemania francia
el perú el país originario de la papa no
nos podemos quedar atrás
frente a nuestra propuesta hubieron
muchas críticas para acá para allá como
siempre lo hay
pero defendí
la creación del día nacional de la papa
porque es la campaña permanente
es la campaña publicitaria permanente
para incrementar el consumo y
desarrollar el mercado
el día nacional de la papa
los celebramos desde 2005 anótenlo 30 de
mayo día nacional de la papa
desde esta fecha
hemos logrado incrementar el consumo de
papas
de 60 kilos que consumíamos en el 2004
hoy día no me va a apuntar pero se lo
voy a decir
consumimos 90 kilos personal
pero déjenme decirles
que yo no estoy contenta
porque nos falta
30 kilos para recuperar los los 120
kilos que consumíamos en los años 60 del
siglo pasado recuerden que yo nací en el
60 y tengo dos edades 58 y mejor me
quedo con 48
el día nacional de la papa
nos ha servido
para hacer una campaña grande
y si de acá nos salen hablando de papá
no sé qué voy a hacer
y comiendo papas discúlpeme pero nos ha
servido
para rescatar a nuestras papas nativas
de la extinción
yo quiero preguntar a calle sido una
pregunta pero no me la respondan porque
el tiempo no me alcanza
ustedes sabían que en nuestro país
tenemos más de 3000 variedades de papas
diferentes en forma color y sabor ya
pero ante todo con muchos poderes
nutricionales y a eso me he dedicado en
mi vida
hablas de papá donde quiera que esté y
seguro presumen invitados
de ese gran número de variedades papas
de pulpas de colores
que tienen unos poderes extraordinarios
quien me dice que papá es yo lo invitó a
comer conmigo en el restaurant y con
virgilio
esta es nuestra papa amarilla tumbay
esta papa tiene un alto contenido de
vitamina c
y un alto contenido de carotenoides
esta papa es con la que elaboramos
estática papilla es el primer alimento
de nuestro bebé yo tengo tres lindos
grandotes
las papas nativas de pulpa de color
miren estas papas deliciosas son
altísimas en macronutrientes fósforo
potasio
además en micronutrientes que tanto se
habló el día hierro y zinc y además en
'la altos en antioxidantes
si quieres quedar joven por siente por
siempre cómo está papá
es la fuente de la eterna juventud
pero en verdad no bastaba con conocer
sus colores
estos atributos que les he compartido si
no lo ponemos al mercado
entonces con una lógica simple
que es de decirles que la gente conozca
sobre nuestras papas y si las conoce la
va a buscar
y luego si quiere comprarlas alguien
tiene que producirlas y alguien tiene
que venderlas
y por una lógica del mercado
estas nuestras papas nativas que estaban
en peligro de extinción
las vamos a salvar
entonces
si se genera todo esto
mirando todos estos temas de mercado
los agricultores la van a sembrar
las van a multiplicar y las van a
conservar entonces ahí se juntan
ustedes suman el poder de la papa con el
poder del mercado
para articular a los productores
organizados
nosotros tenemos una filosofía que es la
siguiente
precio justo al productor precio
accesible al consumidor
trabajamos un modelo de negocio que se
llama compra del campo
ofrecemos y trabajamos papas
seleccionadas y clasificadas
articulando pequeños productores
organizados con supermercados
con grandes restaurantes y otros
negocios
así ha sido posible
colocar al mercado papas de pulpa de
colores que antes no las conocía no se
conocía en nuestras ciudades
nosotros los andinos sí pero acá no
y hoy están donde están quiero compartir
con ustedes
de ese gran grupo de variedades estamos
logrando poner al mercado y hasta en el
mercado estas deliciosas y riquísimas y
bellísimas papas de pulpas de colores
rojos a quienes les hemos mantenido sus
nombres que ya no ten
esta deliciosa papa es una de mis
preferidas todas son mis preferidas
se llama poca jong ho puc a rojos hongo
corazón está papá se llama su max hongo
cuáles son lindos no te estoy enamorando
así se llama la papa así se llama
esta papá se llama wire o macho porque
es larga y de este tamaño
esas de pulpas rojas ahora nos vamos a
las papas de pulpas moradas azules está
papá se llama mejoran delicioso esta
otra papa se llama o en jos es como dos
cachos llama
esta papa león entre las papas de pulpas
azules con estas mismas papas
nosotros hemos colocado en el mercado la
primera marca de hojuelas de papas de
color
y hacen concha y te alimentan
después después de haber superado una
época de crisis
no las que les comenté antes hoy el
sector papel del país es un sector en
crecimiento
nosotros hoy somos los primeros
productores de papas de américa latina-
yo le agrego el caribe
somos en el continente es eeuu
nosotros somos y además en el país
después o sea somos el primer cultivo
nacional
con 4.7 7 millones de toneladas
le sigue el arroz un poco lejos 3
millones le sigue el plátano con 2
millones le sigue el maíz amarillo duro
con 1 le sigue la yuca con 0.95 y los
cultivos de exportación como el café y
el espárrago el café 0.3 y el espárrago
0.38 y ahí me quedo
pero
en el sector necesitamos innovar
necesitamos diversificar
necesitamos industrializar
y es en el esfuerzo en el que estamos en
este momento
estamos al frente del centro de
innovación productiva y transferencia
tecnológica de la papa y los cultivos
andinos del 7 para el 7
y somos una plataforma de servicios para
ser competitiva la cadena de valor de la
papa y los cultivos andinos
trabajamos a nivel nacional
ya sé seamos productores como vitorianos
fernández morales un productor
conservacionista en las alturas del
monte azul en huánuco
a quien lo contactamos con otros
productores conservacionistas del país
le brindamos asesoría técnica lo
articulamos al mercado
con todo el trabajo que hemos realizado
hoy día victoria no ha salido de esta
franja de pobreza no me gusta hablar de
estos temas
y hoy día él
comercializa sus papas todos los
domingos
en la feria de la biodiversidad de la
avenida brasil
también trabajamos
con jóvenes y mujeres como áurea mendoza
áurea
ha aprendido a trasplantar estás
plántulas in vitro
cuál técnico aeroespacial de la nasa
en este invernadero en un invernadero
que está aeroponía donde producimos esto
no en la nasa
eso es en pasco donde producimos
semillas de alta calidad bajo esta
tecnología de aeroponía que es a eros
aerospacial y que lo hemos puesto a la
mano de los productores
al otro extremo
uno de los productores está el consumo
y entonces ahí nos hemos relacionado con
nuestros cocineros pop
a quienes nos estamos evangelizando en
la papa y en nuestra biodiversidad
andina
con algunos de ellos estamos
desarrollando proyectos productivos de
la mano llega alianza con los
productores en el campo
innovar nos lleva por distintas rutas no
pero nosotros vamos un paso adelante
hemos puesto en operación ahorita en
ancash en mi región el primer
laboratorio de multiplicación in vitro
de semillas de alta calidad de papa
hemos desarrollado el primer macerado de
pisco con papas nativas está delicioso
imaginen pisco de con papas pocas hongo
hemos hecho posible en estas alianzas
empresariales está el vodka
el único vodka que el mercado a base de
papas nativas también quiero
compartirles que estamos realizando
trabajos de investigación con la
universidad de wisconsin para
desarrollar envases reciclables a partir
de papas nativas en base al almidón de
papas nativas amargas miren esto esta es
una papa deshidratada y estamos
trabajando con estos envases que van a
reemplazar a los plásticos pero estamos
buscando la fórmula para qué
esos envases vasitos tenedores no los
votes a la basura lo laves y luego se
propagó atom estamos re morado
que sea reutilizable pero en la
alimentación
la papa
ha sobrevivido en nuestro territorio
8000 años
su valor genético es increíble no se
imaginan
y la papa
ahí está para aprovecharla y más ahora
que tenemos todos estos temas de cambio
climático
seguro que varios de los que están en
esta sala han escuchado leído sobre
experimentos que se están haciendo en
ambientes climatizados y simulando marte
pero tengan tengamos presente que cuando
el primer ser humano llega a marte su
primer alimento va a ser la papa
definitivamente porque conozco a la papa
ya los investigadores que están
trabajando esto
y entonces están desarrollando o estamos
incluyo en parte variedades que sean
altamente resistentes
a extremos de temperatura
temperatura alta y mucho frío está en mi
bolsillo etc
y esta es la papa loca me lo vuelvo a
guardar
no
así como así como la papa
me permitió sobrevivir
en el año 70
esa tremenda catástrofe consideró
que hoy en base a todo lo que estamos
trabajando por descubrir y poner a la
vista todos los poderes de nuestra para
para la sobrevivencia de hoy y la del
futuro está garantizada
entonces
la papa para nosotros los peruanos
es un símbolo
de nuestro pasado ancestral
y también es una esperanza para el
futuro gracias
[Aplausos]